i want to start right out of the gate
with something hot as always yesterday
we talked a little bit about guns about
the second amendment
in this country about your right to
self-defense it's a little bit different
over in canada
and i was looking around i saw some
stuff this weekend from prime minister
trudeau who i also call bully trudeau
remember when he bullied the uh the
non-violent truckers in canada who were
fighting against the vaccine mandate
remember when he went into hiding too
yeah
three weeks yeah he was afraid he was
afraid that there were going to be you
know what was going to go on and then he
decided that like any true authoritarian
bully he was going to lock the bank of
counts of those who were contributing to
the truckers so
you know trudeau knows
zero about freedom cares zero about
freedom and like all bullies he had a
little bit of something to say about the
second amendment both in the united
states
and in canada so if you have that clip
let's run that clip and then we'll talk
about it
and
there are debates and we have a a
culture where the difference is guns can
be used for hunting or for sport
shooting in canada and there's lots of
gun owners and they're
mostly lost respecting and law abiding
but you can't use a gun for
self-protection in canada that's not a
right that you have in the constitution
or anywhere else if you try and buy a
gun and say it's for self-protection no
you don't get that you get it for
hunting you can get it for sport
shooting you take the range no problem
as long as you go through our rigorous
background checks but there's a
difference around the culture and one of
the things that we're seeing with the
debate in the states is you get more and
more of the american style you know
right to carry self-defense arguments
filtering up through through the uh you
know the usual more right-wing
communications channels yeah
oh the american style freedom fighters
they really make his blood boil he's an
insufferable human i don't know how else
to say it there are some politicians
that you just disagree with and you're
like you know what they may be a
fundamentally decent person i just see
the world differently from they do
from the way that they do this guy
makes my skin i feel like i have bugs on
me literal bugs on me when i'm watching
him speak how unbelievably condescending
canada i'm sure is a beautiful place the
scenery everything i am very glad i
don't live in canada i would be losing
my mind under that guy for many reasons
but how unbelievably condescending to
say to people well you know you can have
your guns for sport you can have your
guns for you know for hunting but you're
not going to have them for self-defense
so if someone shows up at your doorstep
to rob you huh sorry
i mean can you imagine
and i showed this clip
not just because i think he's an
authoritarian that we need to
acknowledge exists is popular some
people really like him some people in
this country
really like him so i think you need to
say to yourself do you ever want the
united states of america to turn into
canada
to turn into what's going on there right
now you saw what happened with the
truckers
you see what he's saying he's not shy
it's not like in the united states where
you at least have democrats who are
oftentimes reluctant to say things like
okay we're not going to take your guns
we just want some gun restrictions in
place of course many of them want to
take your guns that's a reality they do
they would love that but they're not
going to say it outright because if they
said that there would be a revolution in
this country
he says it outright trudeau just puts it
right out there imagine the audacity
to say that
with a straight face and to just be like
yeah you know that american style
freedom it's just creeping up
huh you should be so lucky
you should be so lucky and you have been
so lucky many of us looked at those
truckers in canada and wondered why
aren't we doing that here why did it
take
something happening in canada why are
those people mobilized in a way that a
lot of people in cities around this
country
should have been mobilized yeah you saw
protests here and there but you didn't
see that we should have seen that here
when those vax mandates hit i was
waiting for it i was going to be out
there you know with my sign waving it
around it wasn't happening i did go to a
couple of protests um and i was
grateful that they existed
but should have been bigger should have
been boulder regardless if you don't
want
the united states to turn into canada on
issues like that if you don't want an
authoritarian like that to have that
kind of power speak up do something
don't wait until it's too late don't sit
back and say oh you know what i'm going
to sit this one out now's not the time
to sit it out
so that's just your reminder your
friendly reminder of what is capable of
happening in this country if you sit
down and shut up it's possible it's 100
possible and i just want to remind you
of that slippery slope because
several years ago we were talking about
obamacare
and we were talking about tyler you
remember when we were talking about
mandates
they were mandating that you had to have
health insurance and the fight was like
no you shouldn't have to have health
insurance if you don't want to have
health insurance
now we're talking about mandating an
experimental vaccine it's like you must
get an injection
so that slippery slope
very slippery remember that slip and
slide you went on when you were a kid
yeah that's it
and it's faster and faster and faster
that's all the time that i want to give
to trudeau because that's all the time
he deserves well real quick do you do
you think canada is salvageable
he just won an election in 2021 yeah
again in 2023.
so i think anywhere not anywhere i think
a lot of places are salvageable but it
depends on people
i i don't know what the appetite is
there
for resistance you saw some of that with
the truckers i was grateful to see that
i don't know what segment of the
population really is utterly disgusted
with what's going on and how many people
are
angry and then how many people are just
complacent right
so
that i would need to have a greater
sense of what's going on on the ground
there i know that here
there's a lot of people that just kind
of sit back
but they push too far this time they
push too far because they came for the
kids right so i think that i think this
whole
notion of pushback is really coming from
a lot of parents right
it's like you'll you'll end you'll
endure and you may know this as a parent
too you'll endure a lot of stuff but
once it gets to your kid you're like oh
you're no leave my kid alone
i don't know if you feel that way oh
absolutely and it's i i was gonna
mention this yesterday but we even
talked about this today on pat's podcast
um
you're starting to see some companies
push back do you remember a couple weeks
ago netflix came out with the memo that
says you know you as an employee you may
not like all of the content that we
produce but we're still going to produce
it anyway right and they were the first
to take a stand
now how long that lasts and whether
other companies follow suit is you know
another story but
like we talked about yesterday you're
seeing daily wire produce their own
content netflix is standing up these
companies are they're starting to get
sick and tired because it's affecting
their bottom line so not just from the
parents but it's going to be good to see
what what kind of pushback we get from
corporate america yeah i think my
concern is that they get a lot away with
a lot when it comes to health
when they can scare you that's the one
area where they realize now they scared
a lot of people and i talked about this
yesterday they scared me they scared a
lot of people and they got away with so
much that now there's a barometer of
like oh
so if we scare the population we can do
x y and z and look how much control they
were able to execute over people's
individual health decisions and
individual lives and where they work and
where they live and a lot wouldn't and
their own business and whether or not
they can food on the table for their own
family for a business that they worked
in and put you know blood sweat and
tears toward for many many years so
i do think there's pushback um
i don't know i don't know where this is
going yet
and i think the midterm elections are
going to say a lot
and i think the next presidential
election is going to say a lot but what
i do hear a lot of people out there that
are like wow we we we were we sat tight
too long and now they're they're some of
the loudest ones the ones like me who
were like i was wiping down my packages
on day one we're some of the loudest
ones we're like oh you played me for a
hot minute
not gonna happen again if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]